This president is is really establishing
a tremendous legacy on the environment
as as well as the economy and I don't
need to speak to the economy.
Let me speak to my issues.
First of all,
I have been engaged since day one on
efforts to reduce carbon pollution.
Most notably in the car industry.
If you take a look at the cause of
today,
you have three times as many models for
sale today as you had when he took
office that are 30 miles a gallon per
gallon or more in terms of their
efficiency.
That is because of actions of this
administration.
We are doubling fuel economy by 2025
we're doing that as a fuel economy
standard and a carbon pollution
standard.
We have been looking at reducing toxic
emissions from utilities.
We actually put forward something that
looks at reducing mercury and arsenic,
things that we haven't been able to move
forward on and the result of that is
that it's already past the compliance
period.
We never threatened reliability.
We got some,
some of those old inefficient units have
gone out that didn't have modern
controls.
Our communities are healthier.
We're saving up to 11,000 lives every
year ever was.
As a result of that,
we have renewables when three times as
much as when this,
when this president came into office 10
times more solar than we've ever had and
these are becoming competitive
technologies.
We have also have grown in the,
in the building trades in terms of how
you build energy efficient homes and
buildings.
We have grown thousands and thousands of
jobs.
We are building the the economy of the
future by building in your
considerations on environment into those
decisions.
We're looking at water rules today.
I am actually moving forward with a
final rule that is going to settle the
question of what waters are important to
protect so we can protect people's
drinking water into the future and how
do we adapt to a changing climate.
When you have California with such
significant water shortages,
what does that mean?
How do we change the way we do business?
And instead of piping water out,
we're looking at green infrastructure
moving in.
So we have a tremendous rich legacy that
this president is going to leave.
And I think climate is,
is really going to be the one that's
most talked about.
But frankly,
our legacy needs to be that we're nimble
enough as a government and as states
working with the federal government to
be able to see what the challenges are
today and to position our solutions in
ways that grow,
uh,
our ability to tackle the problems of
the future.